[Music]
so Amazon's got a new show called the
Grand chore it takes the guys from BBC's
Top Gear as they like travel around the
world doing awesome stuff so inspired by
them or challenging each other to a
demolition derby
it's like bumper cars for adults I just
can't wait to Ram my friends oh you know
what this probably a better way to say
that so we're gonna get into cars get
into a ring and crash up into each other
think white people came up with this
right I have only been in a couple of
accidents I accidentally hit a parked
car one time I am nervous I don't like
pain and getting into car crashes is
pain I've actually never hit another car
before so I've saved it all up in a day
I'm ready to really unleash what I'm
most scared of is the personal vendettas
we might have against each other rearing
their ugly heads
did I say scared though I'm very excited
about that hi John and Greg I am like so
excited to do this is everything you're
told not to do and now we get to do it
they refer to a car's our second biggest
investment of our lives and now to take
a car and totally demolish it sounds
wrong now have either of you ever
participated in a demolition derby no
way so death is imminent no not at all
in mind I've never done it we move
flammables out of cars for removing the
glass out of the cars though doors are
welded closed the trunks are welded
closed we put a bar on the front that
keeps the food or anything from coming
back into the driver's compartment and
there's braces put on the car you want
to protect the front of this car because
that's where the engine is that's its
life that's its heart so you wish to use
the back to your car to inflict damage
so demolition derby is basically backing
that ass up this thing is a total
slugfest see 20 guys gonna probably end
up taking a hit that's gonna knock the
change out of your ashtray that's gonna
be a real rock and roll moments go pick
out our cars drivers
let's go fellas yeah oh I want this one
no I want that one
Eugene and I both spotted this car and
we wanted it bad but it's a stick though
can you drive stick
yeah imma kill you net you can't beat
the tank the tank beats you oh this
feels so wrong yet so right I like this
one you know I can stand up in it we
have wipes or any kind of disinfecting
spray I think I'm gonna take this one
it looks nastier look at it we're
supposed to be picking out our cars he's
driving his around
yeah he's either doing things too early
or talking about his wife and I'm tired
of both that's good why don't you wanna
just hit him that's all girlfriend let's
all go for that roosters business all
right you guys ready for a makeover to
the Duke adieu montage montage montage
makeover montage boom boom boom makeover
I did not expect that much thrust the
demolition derby community is very
competitive and it's competitive all the
way down to decorating you know what
yours needs just like a little pink
right now about it look how cute
oh okay come on let's wait that's that's
fine look it's a little heart yeah my
vision for my car is I want to be
dangerous I want to be lethal won't be
sleek I wanna be like a panther oh that
love goal it's trying to go for like a
classic racer design invoking a bit of
the like early 90s late 80s vibe I love
the signature sex I have a cousin in the
Marines my grandfather fought in World
War two I want to honor the troops today
with a badass World War two fighting
machine I think I'm getting low contact
high off of these fumes this is you this
is a Eugene and this is Keith yeah that
did dang that's beauty you're welcome my
car's gonna be named the aerial I am
which is why I'm not gonna let them
wreck it please stop this line of joke
making it's not just a demolition derby
it's a decoration derby my approach is
to make the most obscenely adorable car
what's more infuriating and getting
beaten by something that's so cute
things like that
yeah it's coming together well but there
is one thing you have any extra faces a
few more faces yeah just I feel like I
want one of you in my - about a Fire's
okay great sipar I'm gonna have my face
everywhere that way when everybody's
driving and they're getting intense they
can see my friendly face to me you know
what I don't want to hit Keith look at
that smile I'm making this car into me
like a fancy pair of socks oh my
goodness this car screams Keith hey who
drew a mustache down pretty old Keith if
anything I guess it's a good decoy right
you could be like oh hey Keith Oh
exactly that's not Keith at the end of
day you're gonna see a teen smiling
these looking straight at you in victory
when I went I went or at least get
second place what up I'm Zack and this
my whip
meow-meow her name is Donna and she is
perfect
we got paw print decal we got a
beautiful face we got lightning bolts
down the side we got a tail not purely
aesthetic the tail it's for balance
that's how cats work the more obnoxious
my car is the more there's gonna be so
pissed off when I attack them this is
the aerial they named it after my wife
she's a classy lady but she's also
really tough here's me and my wife
holding hands
I feel like demolition derby is classic
Americana so I wanted to put as many
American elements on it as I could
war is a terrible thing my friend but
today we're gonna kill cars
we're gonna kill cars this is my
beautiful baby its name is black magic I
kind of went less for loud and
extravagant and for more of a subtle
elegant approach black magic is my soul
in a car like the night sky dark
mysterious is still very sparkly this is
my car Keith - I wanted to make sure
everybody knew who was driving this car
our experts said that if I was too
pretty too loud it might make me a
target
that's why I've put nothing but friendly
faces and concerned faces as the basis
on this car Oh watch out I'm about to
bust your asses are you guys ready for
the Derby today don't have a choice
really uh-huh
ever gotten injured during a demolition
derby beginning of this here I broke two
ribs someone head-on with another truck
you still won the Derby more I talk to
you guys the worse I feel what are the
different things in the car that can
stop it we lose the radiator your motor
will overheat in about five minutes so
if you see a bunch of water and steam
coming out your car go hit somebody
really hard because I'll probably the
last thing you get to do cuz that's it
so make it count what happens if it
comes down to the end there are two cars
left and they both break at the same
time at that point we would get the
drivers out and a fan but what happened
it ends in a dance-off it ends in a
dance-off
the three nonno's do not hit the
driver's door on purposes number one
number two is do not hit the driver's
door on purpose and number three is
protecting your nose seeing your car and
your nose because doing one and two
could tend to get your nose socked after
the event you guys wouldn't punch me
though would you after you hit the
driver's door that prize for the person
who hits the most number cars
yeah it's called the mad dog award it's
normally bigger than winning the Derby
there's basically three big awards right
winner of the Derby Mad Dog award for
whose most aggressive and the best
decorated car that so we could all
potentially winning something except for
one person is there so today there will
be one shitty shitty loser let's get in
them and take them for a test drive
every time we do a video Tom Welles
competition Ned turns into a monster all
the other guys think I'm gonna be
aggressive
I'm gonna try and be really cautious
evading the hits and then when all three
the other guys are piled up on each
other boom that's where I deliver the
final blow so we are teaming up on it
right yeah we have established that I am
the best driver and the try guys it's a
fact I think I actually stand a chance
today you know I'm good at driving I'm
good at breaking stuff that is Zach's
brain yeah if you ask all the try guys
individually who the best friend is they
say me I love Keith
I mean Keith is the best and they're not
gonna expect me to be aggressive I'm
gonna be so aggressive they're gonna be
like wow Keith I didn't expect that from
you I'll be like that's right fellas
this might be my favorite car to hit I
think Eugene's gonna be super aggressive
go out of the gate screaming overheat
his car anything that involves killing
your friends on accident I'm down for
[Music]
oh man okay this is it we are here you
know at first I was a little nervous but
now I just want to hit somebody oh man
I've been playing it cool but I'm not
keeping it cool I'm ready to go my true
hope is that I'm just too adorable or
someone I want to hurt about to see
whole new side of hammers burger let's
do this
[Music]
oh that's my
Oh
Oh get him out of there
they told us that that's something you
get ejected for voices of Keith and Zack
saying remember our alliance go after
Ned just went out the window
at one point that not got adjustable
straight away at each other and that
hurt I got him in my sights and aah
smacked into him after that hit from
dead there was a part of me that was
like I'm done I can't take any more
talks about what hurt
[Music]
have a new manager start steaming it
like they said they said if it starts to
steam suicide mission just dive into
everybody face first
so I was just him and it was still
running
just colliding with people head-on I'm
crazy
no three guys apparently had an alliance
to gang up on me so anytime I hit
somebody it would just be to other cars
around me and I would be stuck think I'm
out
[Music]
[ __ ] keep got one little clip on my
corner and my battery went when
Blackmagic sputtered to its and
experienced the worst case of blue balls
I've ever had for destruction come on
[Music]
you might are you got me that was good
feel like I [ __ ] everybody yeah real
hard hit my dog you know my door oh I'll
take your hit man my driver side door
whoa I'm sorry man
I really did try and stop the last
second I didn't know what I was doing
[Music]
well fellas did you have fun yeah that's
awesome amazing so as far as the winner
goes it was kind of obvious because it's
the last man standing so Eric who was it
the kitty cat Zach oh god oh yeah I've
never felt like this before I just would
have feels liked until like sport
touchdown or something what I'd do it
again [ __ ] no I am in so much pain
so best appearing he accomplished two
things today he won best appearing and
he blew the motor up in the carnet
ah it's very exciting because I was
really proud of my design and honestly
if you hate my design
you hate America so now we'll go to the
mad dog award there is one car in here
that has every paint color from every
other car on it and it's full of faces
and you guys believe I was the Mad Dog
Mad No put it up row row row row row row
oh my go I don't want to make Eugene
feel bad but I just want to point out
that there was only one loser
shishi I'm glad that I lost I think it's
a good feeling to know that darkness
should not win I had so much joy trying
to legitimately murder my friends she is
the only loser I can't believe it that
we did it we finally did it guys you got
one two three we'll free straight one
two three yeah
I know we didn't get there but like if
we did could you judge a dance hall
could you give us a beat Eric wow wow
wow and then you go back to debit and
add to that top that Eugene didn't quite
loose it's a lot